le gouvernement du québec a présenté son
plan pour prévenir et contrer les
violences sexuelles avec 55 actions mais
voici ce qui devrait y avoir selon des
gars qui étudie à l'université laval
le but sensibiliser les jeunes aux
primaires secondaires
ben qu'est ce que le monde doit passer
de moins que je perde mon ami je pense
juste d'enlever ses valeurs et à ses
plans à la source de montrer aux jeunes
garçons avec la femme n'est pas un objet
ça peut passer par des vidéos youtube
ça peut passer par instagram snapshot
5340 agressions sexuelles et autres
infractions d'ordre sexuel ont eu lieu
en 2014 selon les corps policiers
québécois 84 % étaient des filles et des
femmes parmi les victimes qu'il faut
croire les victimes qu'il faut aller au
fond du processus judiciaire
puis il faut également donner des peines
qui correspondent aux créer une question
que les gens qui sont là pour appliquer
la loi soit conscientiser aussi
assouplir la loi n est pas seulement
elle n'est pas suffisante pour protéger
contre les agressions sexuelles ça
serait de réimplanter dans les écoles
l'éducation à la sexualité
or justement abordé les questions vu
consentement parce que souvent ça serait
pas la maison fait des cours aux niveaux
primaire secondaire ça serait vraiment
une bonne vie pour comprendre c'est quoi
le consentement
il devrait avoir fait un disque plus de
sécurité sur les endroits plus à risque
je prends par exemple qui s'est passé à
l'université c'est juste inacceptable
c'est juste une question de sécurité